[Music]
why don't we go next to um
let's go to casey from oklahoma city
casey you're on the air
hey david hear me okay yes i can
um with the texas heartbeat uh act
oklahoma planned parenthood i mean they
saw a jump i think in
roughly like two thousand twenty-five
hundred percent in uh patients
uh but governor stanton who's often the
little brother of the states and
governors like you know desantis and
abbott just signed a law that would
basically upend it
here in oklahoma and ban it yep to
include like hundred thousand dollars in
fines plus ten-year prison sentence we
did cover that story earlier this week
it's crazy what oklahoma's doing on
abortion yeah
yeah um
but i find that we often talk about at
least in the counter we talk about rape
and incest but one of the things i never
hear about is teen pregnancy and if we
look at the top states and teen
pregnancies greater than uh 30 per every
thousand burst guess what they're all
they're all republic republican states
of course south carolina arizona alabama
tennessee you know i can go down the
list
do you think that would
help these pro-life people to think
twice when
we put we frame it that the the teen
pregnancies who are their daughters
uh do you want them to keep that child
or do they say well morally my daughter
should keep it
um so
usually they will sidestep this issue
you're absolutely right which is the
places that uh have the highest rates of
teen pregnancy are mostly red states
that's absolutely true
republicans will sidestep this by saying
if we were correctly teaching abstinence
only say
abstinence only sex education they
wouldn't be getting pregnant in the
first place now of course they're wrong
but they want the total package which is
ban abortion and teach abstinence only
you know it doesn't work i know it
doesn't work but that's what they will
say
i mean i would think the country to that
is isn't that what you already preach in
your states and obviously it's not
working it's not working no but then
they'll come in and they'll say no but
these public schools with the critical
race theory and the gender stuff and the
teaching kids how to have sex and these
things they'll just say it's not it's
what we want but it's not actually
happening teachers are injecting it into
the classroom
yeah and it's uh i left a voicemail last
night about uh radio station here
locally and and if you go to like the
fcc
uh they can't do anything as far as
freedom of speech which i'm all for you
know freedom
uh but the the propaganda from because
they're playing like infowars
and and talking about demonic baby
pedophile all this stuff is just
infuriating and i don't know the
solution to it because it's just
making people stronger in their beliefs
that are just untrue it's lunacy it's
lunacy yeah
well listen good luck there in oklahoma
because it's getting pretty grim i'm not
gonna lie yeah it is
yeah all right casey thank you for the
call thank you all right there's casey
from oklahoma the site of a horrifying
horrifying horrifying abortion bill
let's go to tristan from boston tristan
you're on the air
hey david can you hear me yes i can
cool
it occurred to me recently uh have you
considered writing a book
yes uh in fact i'm working on a proposal
right now it's a big project it's a long
process but i am working on that right
now
wow that's actually pretty cool yeah uh
if you don't mind me asking uh
what is the subject i i don't want to
say because we're still workshopping it
and then it i might end up kind of
self-cucking you know i don't want to do
that
yeah does that uh include elements of
many subjects it actually does it
actually does yeah it's so it's a
multi-disciplinary proposal
i mean
i would feel like the
the main topics the ideas for the main
topics would be pretty obvious
well we'll find out won't we tristan
considering you're considering your
fields of expertise sure sure yeah no
when i have more to say about it i
absolutely will but it's something i am
working on
that's actually great to hear i would i
would 100
i'm totally pumped to hear that
well good it sounds like at least i'd
sell one copy
yeah i can't wait to see it all right
tristan thank you so much
awesome all right there's tristan from
boston asking about
a book project thanks to everybody who
called in my apologies to everybody i
couldn't get to we'll take calls again
and for now we will take a very quick
break and be right back